[Music]
a central idea and also in the narrative
reality within ursula k le guin's sixth
earth sea novel the other wind is what
is referred to
in kargish as the verduron
and in the old speech the true speech
the ver nadan
both of these signify the same thing and
we're going to
see allusions to it early on and then it
really only gets explored and explained
in the fifth chapter what it means is
some sort of agreement but also
a division
between different peoples
and it's made but it's also broken and
it's part of the
history of earthsea as it's being
revealed to us in this this final novel
this final
narrative that leguin
has
things being uncovered and compared and
and finally figured out and resolved
but it's also something that is pressing
for the characters then so it's part of
their history it's also part of their
destiny you might say and the choices
that they have to make so the early
references to it the first reference is
actually in the mouth of the kargish
princess talking to tennar cesar rock
and what what cesaro
says is um they're talking about dragons
and being reborn
and all of that that sort of thing
and she says um
the story is about the accursed
sorcerers discovering
the verdernan that was the thing i don't
know what it was that told some people
that if they'd agree never to die
and never to be reborn they could learn
how to do sorcery so they chose that
they chose the verter nun
and
they went off into the west with it and
it turned them dark and they live here
all these people here they're the ones
who chose it they live and they can do
their accursed sorceries but they can't
die only their bodies die
the rest of them stays in a dark place
and never gets reborn and they look like
birds but they can't fly so this is the
kargish
point of view
on this and this is going to turn out to
be a misrepresentation a bit of a
distortion but it also contains a deep
truth to it and
this recalls to tenor's mind the story
of the woman of kameh in the beginning
of time mankind and the dragons had been
won but the dragons chose wildness and
freedom and mankind chose wealth and
power a choice of separation was it the
same
story
and then
caesareach says it's not that ring is it
that they kept talking about that i'm
going to have to wear and she says ring
no no that's not the ring
it's something completely different and
they get onto a different track talking
about names and sorcery and stuff like
that
then a little bit later
we find the term coming up again
but now in the old speech
this is sepal talking the
pelnish wizard and the polish you know
are viewed with kind of suspicion by the
wizards and mages of rogue in part
because of the pelnish lore which he has
to do with you know the the dead and
overcoming death and
they're talking about immortality
and you know what the dead actually want
alder says they want to be free
and then sepal says maybe it was a bad
bargain
from the beginning
vernadan
alder knew the words were in the old
speech but he did not know
their
meaning
and so now we see this coming up again
right and these are the same
word one in cargish and
one in
the old speech right and nobody actually
says anything about it in heartache
so those are the first things and then
much later tenor says okay you need to
tell
lebanon your you know husband-to-be
and the king the account that you have
and so cesarok
actually goes into this and says
long ago card people sorcery people
dragging people hi yes all people all
speak one
one language
in a passionate attempt to speak heartic
she was losing her self-consciousness
but then dragon people say let go let go
all things fly but we people we say no
keep keep all things dwell so we go
apart dragon people and we people so
they make the verdanan these to let go
these to keep yes but to keep all things
we must let go that language the dragon
people
language the old speech lebanon says yes
so we people we let go that old speech
language and keep all things and dragon
people let go all things but keep that
keep the language this is the verdanan
we go east east dragon people go west
west west
we dwell they fly some dragon come east
with us but not keep the language forget
and forget to fly like karg people card
people speak karg language not dragon
language all keep the verdana east west
sanaya but in at a law she brought her
hands together from east and west and
lebanon said in the middle ah yes in the
middle
in the middle you sorcery people you
middle people speak heartache language
but two
also keep to speak old speech language
you learn it like i learn heartache
learn to speak then this this is the bad
the bad thing you say in that sorcery
language in that old speech language we
will not to die and it is so and the
verdanan is
broken
so the agreement the splitting apart of
dragonkind and humankind is honored by
the kargs but not by the
mass of the archipelagons
in earthsea at least some of whom
actually many of whom
learn the the old speech and learn to
use magic which is not entirely of the
old speech after all there are the old
powers of the earth and there are other
things that that you know function in
magic but names in the old speech is
really central so learning the old
speech is a breaking
of this agreement instead of everybody
going to their separate corners and and
being okay with that there's this
intermixing this sort of familial
everybody being up in each other's
business
later
osvar the
uh
mage the patterner is going to
the name is going to tell no the pattern
is going to
tell another
account of this now he's also a card so
you have to keep that in mind
and
he goes on and he tells an account
in which there is yet another
version of the
the story that goes on
and he uh
he tells
them
that when he was a boy
he learned uh here we go
the humans beings went east the dragons
west the humans gave up their knowledge
of the language of the making and in
exchange received all skill and craft of
hand and ownership of all that hands can
make the dragons let go such things they
kept the old speech and their wings and
their wings lebanon said he'd caught
ozra's eyes patterner perhaps you can
continue the story better than i
and then azra says something really
interesting the villagers at gant
and her at her
remember what the wise men of rock and
the priests of corrego forget
yes as a child i was told this tale i
think or something like it but the
dragons had been forgotten in it
it told how the dark folk of the
archipelago broke their oath their oath
to who them not to the dragons
to the kargish people at one time human
human beings were all one people
and the kargs kept the agreement and the
archipelagons broke it we had all
promised to forgo sorcery in the
language of sorcery speaking only our
common tongue we would name no names
make no spells we would trust to
so [ __ ]
to the powers of the earth our mother
mother of the warrior gods but the dark
folk
broke the covenant they caught the
language of the making in their craft
writing it in runes they kept it taught
it used it they made spells with it with
a skill of their hands with false
tongues speaking true words so the
karkish people can never trust them so
says the tale so now we have
two different stories about what's going
on one is humans and dragons which maps
on to the story
about
human beings and dragons told by the
woman of kameh
ozra has this child story
but then he tells another story
another account
he says that
i will give you i will say
um what i have half learned half guessed
not from village tales but from the most
ancient records in the isolate tower a
thousand years before the first kings of
enlarge there were men in aya and solea
the first and greatest of the mages the
rune makers
it was they who learned to write the
language of the making they made the
runes
which the dragons never learned and they
taught us to give each soul
each human soul each person its true
name which is its truth itself and with
their power they granted to those who
bear their true name beyond the body's
death now we're getting to something
different here
it's no longer just
being able to do sorcery and you know
not leaving the dragon's language behind
or the original language behind
now it's about
life and death
life immortal sepal's soft voice took
the word he spoke smiling a little in a
great land of rivers and mountains and
beautiful cities where there's no
suffering or pain where the self endures
unchanged unchanging forever that is the
dream of the ancient lore of palm so
some
magic users those using the pelnish lord
or the lore of palm based in that island
based in that tradition
were trying to
you know get people to be able to live
forever
in a land that would be wonderful
unchanging not like the world we live in
here's where it starts to get really
interesting
where the summoner said where is that
land
and now irian the dragon
says it's on the other wind you dummies
this is part of why
we're upset with you we dragons right
the west beyond the west now in the
story of the woman of kameh the west
beyond the west is where
the
other people went who were
you know sort of both human and dragon
right
and what do we find out she says
do you think our freedom is no greater
than that of the mindless seagulls you
are in the only earth you own the sea we
are the fire of sunlight we fly the wind
you wanted land to own you wanted things
to make and keep and you have that that
was the division the verona she's
telling us what the veronita was but you
were not content with your share you
wanted not only your cares but our
freedom you wanted the wind and by the
spells and wizardries of those oath
breakers who are the oath breakers these
original mages you stole half our realm
from us walled it away from life and
light so you could live there forever so
the dragons had their portion and the
human beings took half of that
portion half of that land of immortality
azer says after that the ancients saw
the dragon's realm was not of the body
only
they could fly outside of time it may be
and envying that freedom they followed
the dragon's way into the west beyond
the west they claimed part of that realm
as their own a timeless realm where the
self might be forever but not in the
body as the dragons were only in spirit
could men be there
so they made a wall which no living body
could cross
neither man nor dragon and their arts of
naming made a great net of spells on all
the western lands so when the people of
the islands die they would come to the
west beyond the west and live there in
the spirit forever so this is what the
pellish lord was talking about this is
what those original mages did they
created the walls of stones
but
doing that
created the dry land
and as the story goes on
as the wall was built and the spell laid
the wind ceased to blow within the wall
the sea withdrew
the spring ceased to run the mountains
of sunrise became the mountains of the
night those who died came to a dark land
a dry land so the the dark land the dry
land the two really important things
we're learning it was a human creation
out of the raw material of
the world and the place west beyond the
west the other wind
but it also went awry it turned into
something
that it wasn't supposed to be
and so the dragons were angry because
some other their land was stolen and
nobody wants to go to the dry land and
it becomes sort of a
you know
a terrible place that is only a mockery
of immortality then we have cobb and
thorian stirring stuff up you know
trying to break the boundary between
living and dead
and
this
makes the dead restless but also
makes the dragons remember that the
human beings had broken this agreement
with them
and so
you know now the question is what will
they
do how will they
address this
interestingly the person who has you
might say the last word on this is the
door keeper
right the master door keeper he says
i think maybe the division that was
begun and then betrayed will be
completed at last the dragons will go
free and leave us here to the choice we
made
the knowledge of good and evil said onyx
the joy of making shaping says
sepal our mastery and our greed our
weakness our fear says osvar
and so
there's the possibility that things can
be indeed
fixed that this
agreement
now now broken can be
in some respect restored but that will
be a complete division
you